tonight joe biden's radical extreme
socialist agenda
is taking yet another step to the left
as the weak the frail the ever
struggling cognitively joe biden ordered
a commission
to study the effects of judicial reform
for now first and foremost you got to
remember
he wants to distract all of us from the
disaster at the border but this is
important
translation biden his team far left
socialist democrats
they want to pack the court they want to
stack it with radical
far-left activists they want to overhaul
one of the most sacred institutions in
our country
and turn it into yet another arm of the
democratic party
and more power for them that is the only
way they will actually be able to
implement what is their destructive
economy killing socialist agenda
and maintain power now under biden's
order a 36-member commission will have
180 days
to hold hearings evaluate various court
reform measures
and what is just the latest example of
biden surrendering
to the far left fringe socialist friends
the dc sewer swamp on steroids and human
growth hormone
now we told you all of this was coming
this should not be a surprise but
now they're hoping to make this a
reality court packing is nothing but a
corrupt scheme whereby a president
increases the number of justices giving
him an opportunity to nominate
endless judges that would rule in his
favor and likely support his
radical socialist agenda it would be the
biggest
and most destabilizing power grab in 150
years in this country if actually
implemented
the supreme court would no longer
function as a co-equal branch of
government
it would no longer be the check and the
balance of the executive branch and
legislative branch
it would simply serve as an extension of
this new
extreme democratic party but remember
biden didn't always support the idea of
court packing
thank goodness for videotape now you can
listen to biden all the way back in 1983
calling it a bone-headed idea by the way
joe
if you're still awake likely not it
still is
take a look president roosevelt clearly
had the right to send to the united
states senate the united states congress
a proposal to pack the court
it was totally within his right to do
that he violated no law
he was legalistically absolutely correct
but it was a bonehead idea it was a
terrible terrible mistake to make and it
put in question
for an entire decade the independence of
the most significant body including the
congress in my view
the most significant body in this
country the supreme court of the united
states of america
now we all know once biden decided to
run for president decades later
decided to be totally controlled by the
extreme left
if he really even knows now everything's
changed
now here he is on fake news 60 minutes
by the way more corrupt than ever after
last weekend with governor ron desantis
but here's biden saying that the courts
were quote getting
out of whack joe do you even remember do
you know what day it is
take a look if elected what i will do is
i'll put together a national commission
of
bipartisan commission of scholars
constitutional scholars
democrats republicans liberal
conservatives
and i will ask them to over a
180 days come back to me with
recommendations as to how
to reform the court system because it's
getting out of whack
the way in which it's being handled and
it's not about court packing there's a
number of other things that our
constitutional scholars have debated and
i'd look to see what recommendations
that commission might make
so you're telling us you're going to
study this issue about whether to pack
the court no whether there's a number of
alternatives that are go
well beyond packing so biden in the
candidate
campaign protection program right the
media mob protected him the whole time
didn't ask him tough questions
remember biden refused to directly
answer if he supported court packing
we knew better tonight just like we've
been telling you
the answer is a resounding yes because
democrats are always looking for ways
to get power rule this country and they
want power in perpetuity
they don't like checks and balances they
don't value
our constitution our constitutional
republic
they don't value equal justice they
certainly don't really give a damn about
any of your rights
and don't forget about biden he put out
all of these far left promises
remember he wrote them down the biden
the bernie manifesto
they released that last summer we were
the one of the few programs in the
country to actually cover it
and tell you what was in it everything
biden is doing
open borders amnesty his yes let's kill
off the entire energy sector his
policies of being
energy dependent tax hikes far left
lawlessness
it was all in writing for everyone to
see the biden bernie unity
task force recommendations and on next
week's docket by the way
it doesn't end d.c statehood and
reparations
we will be debating all of that but
let's look at biden's new budget
proposal packed with an increase in
federal spending
packed with far left climate climate
measures that in reality
will do little to nothing to improve the
environment
but it will increase government control
over every single aspect of your
day-to-day life
and i'm telling you when these far left
radical socialists
tell you what they're plotting and
planning and scheming you need to
believe them
we're seeing it all play out day after
day i can tell you right now
the midterm election in 2022 is more
important than any other election
in our lifetime and 2024 after that
the coveted relief bill they lied to you
it wasn't about
covet emergency relief no that was about
bailing out blue states that mismanaged
their money
this infrastructure bill it's about
everything
other than infrastructure h.r 1 sr1
voting overhauls no voter id no
signature verification
that will surrender total control of our
elections to democrats
and the federal government by the way
d.c puerto rico
stated oh democrats see that as four new
democratic senators in perpetuity
biden's gun orders have nothing to do
with safety and security
everything to do with undermining the
second amendment
and by the way ask yourself is there
anything that democrats
are actually proposing that will improve
the quality of your life
energy costs through the roof you're all
paying more we're all paying more
taxes are going up corporations don't
pay taxes
they will pass that on to you the cost
of starting running a business
that is going up crime is going through
the roof
a lot of good that defund the police
effort did borders are wide open
it's costing us a fortune our country is
becoming less safe less secure by the
hour
and the democrats their solution is to
disarm you and defund the police
all while these far left policies are
failing all across the country
all the way from new york to los angeles
and pretty much every other
democratic-run city in between
look at all these cities run by liberal
democrats for decades every time they
take control
an absolute nightmare no law and order
no safety security
the worst schools and i don't think that
obamacare thing worked out either
that is not stopping the leftists in
washington from trying to turn the
entire
country into new york and california you
like what's happening in new york
you like california keep supporting joe
biden
if you value this constitutional
republic our
system limited government capitalism
prosperity
co-equal branches of government private
property
our very way of life then you better pay
attention because
these unhinged left-wing radical
extremists
they have an insatiable appetite a quest
for power
at all costs now it's more undeniable
than ever